I'm the first biggity and we're actually
talking about speaking with and actually
with power um well you know like like I
like oh so today we're talking about
speaking and acting with power and I
know that all of us deal with this
everyday and um you know it's something
that sometimes we kind of get lost you
don't know where our sight my slice here
for example yeah and so you know like no
stop it doesn't go this way your parents
your guess Church and obvious like a
federation everything place against you
but it's not about bow it's all about us
every day we have a lot of conversations
without protesters with our friends with
our classmates and we easily may find
ourselves in the situation when they
unintentionally lose our power so today
we would like to focus on communication
skill that will allow you to gain your
power intentionally and to avoid a
situation when you lose your power
accidentally and these communication
skills are acting and speaking with
power so in the first part of our
presentation we would like to talk about
acting with power doing for example a
presentation at work then we would like
to move on speaking less power because
sometimes there is no opportunity to act
with power for example on a phone
interview the only opportunity to
communicate your power is to speak this
power so now let's come back to the
beginning of our presentation and let's
look what mistakes Bhau did and how she
could do it differently
right so obviously bad most of those to
do it is a lot better than she did today
but she did a few mistakes that we're
going to go through today just to give
you an example of what you can do to
make it better so the first seconds
how did she appear what is what is the
first impression you have from your
appearance acting with power means
appearing powerful having status in the
room and the way she looked was just not
appropriate for this audience there are
studies that show that when you have a
proper dress when you have a suit when
you have a uniform something that
attributes status to you people will
perceive you as powerful and power I
didn't do it the second thing that boded
is she didn't look very prepared it was
very obvious that no she kind of had to
look for her notes she had to cling on
to the fact that you had on the paper
she even was pointing to us and kind of
looking for help and when you activate
power you're on your own people who
perceive you as the person who is in
charge and who knows what to do and you
don't don't look for excuses one very
important thing about acting with power
is don't don't apologize don't be sorry
don't be sad in case of doubt it's
better to come across as aggressive then
about then then coming across is said
and the last point is her gestures her
postures we've heard a lot about that
today but just a few key points where
did you stand in the room here with her
knows she was hiding where you want to
be is you want to be on the stage you
want to occupy the stage you want to
have you want to have you know some
presence and it's about did a great job
in kind of like twisting around and
showing this and that's not where you
want to be you want to be right here in
the middle and you want to come
educate and establish your presence with
your audience with that I'd like to
invite fans and Lana to this to the
stage to show us another example about
to speak with our so good morning mr.
Smith
good morning Svetlana so Svetlana what
do you think is great about working at
Google oh yeah you know before I entered
Stanford Business School I often
McKinsey and oh I read there too
I was in the South Africa office oh
really
oh I'm sorry Smith may continue so we
had a great project with Google and I
realized that this is a great company
and I like its complete culture it
promotes innovation and independent
thinking and I really need intellectual
flexibility
I also like its mission the company's
mission is about organizing information
and making it accessible all over the
world and people here Google has a lot
of very smart talented people it's a
great pleasure to of their and fadh yeah
yeah I like fun I think it's really
funny to walk and go and then oh yeah
intrapreneurship yeah oh yeah that's
right
what would you say your greatest
strengths are um yeah I think I'm a
proactive person I always try to go
beyond my direct responsibilities and
add value to any task that I do and
exceed the expectations
I'm also very supportive person and if
not
when you join it you want to be the
center of attention when you do an
interview you want to speak with power
be if you want to be William wants
people to remember where he is when
you're doing a presentation or you are
Jason who's a regular speaker here at
the GSB or you're like Gd who is the
inspirational teacher for all of us you
want to speak with power and today I'm
going to introduce to everyone three
different ways to speak with power
firstly interruptions what could be now
a hand there and I could take that
question but what is better would be for
me to say I'll take that question later
let me continue with what I have to say
the good thing about doing that is one
that you keep your audience focused on
you and what your train of thoughts are
to you make sure that they are not
distracted by any questions that come up
and three you maintain control you keep
control of what the scene is like and
where the conversation is going
the second point have the list of three
not one not two but three now having
three clear and concise points help
people know what they want to take away
from your talk secondly it helps you
remember what you have to say I remember
now that I have three different points
and my third point which I haven't
covered tells you that you want to take
away three different points today from
our presentation and in make sure that
the audience keep track with what they
are actually listening about the last
point you want to have contrasting
points why contrast what happened to set
Lana earlier on when she said I
proactive um I you know usually
participate and I make sure that
everyone is involved now that that's all
of us I'm pretty sure given you guys are
GSB students um but what could be better
would be for you to say I had a
colleague once who
never took the initiative but rather I
decided that I wanted to do this all
that instead
hence what could have been a really good
interview for Solana was ruined because
she allowed interruptions because she
did not have three clear and concise
points and she did not use the power of
contrast now what could be for everyone
here is going to take control for you to
be clear and concise in your points and
finally to use the power of contrast
that could make you all the better
speakers and the powerful speakers that
we all aim to be I will now pass on to
say to give your clear and concise
concrete actions to take to reach this
goal so we have seen how not to act and
speak with power and we have told you
how to act and speak with power but why
does this matter to you the answer lies
in each and every one of your calendars
you have job interviews you have
presentations and you have networking
events acting and speaking with power at
a job interrview will allow you to
communicate your expertise and core
competencies excellently landing you
that dream job at a presentation acting
and speaking with power will allow you
to be more persuasive really driving
home those final points and at
networking events imagine you're in a
room full of hundreds of people
everyone looking to stand out but how do
you do that the best way is to use
acting and speaking with power to
separate yourself making you stand out
from the crowd
turning turning yourself from one of
those people who are looking for other
people to to potentially notice them to
that person who has everyone gravitate
towards them so what's the takeaway for
you today we have created what we have
aptly named a day to day guide to power
it is a list of items you can use every
single day to make you a person you more
frequently acts and speaks with power by
going through this guide within a week
maybe two you will be seen and perceived
by your peers or and friends to be a
much more powerful speaker with the goal
that you are better at in at
interviewing better at presenting and
also better at networking as well making
you be perfectly most well-rounded
professional you could ever possibly be
you